I just kind of wanted to lay it all out
there and be completely open Sean Lowe
is addressing the apparent suicide of
former bachelor contestant Lex
McAllister who reportedly overdosed on
pills on February 16th in an emotional
blog post the bachelor star calls the
suicide rate of reality stars a quote
epidemic Lex's death comes a few years
after Gia allemand committed suicide in
2013 they both competed on Jake Pavelka
season Bachelorette contestant Julian
hug also committed suicide in 2010 Shawn
writes quote three people from the
bachelor family committing suicide
should cause us all to pause Sean notes
he does not know whether reality TV
contestants actually have higher suicide
rates but cites there have been 21
reality contestants suicides since 2004
the 32 year old shares his faith based
perspective writing suicide is not the
answer
and says there is hope for people who
are sad after one commentator pointed
out that several suicides stemmed from
mental illness Shawn updated his post
writing quote mental illness is a
disease which ensnares tens of thousands
of people each year and takes them to
places which they would have never taken
themselves my sincerest apologies for
not making my points more clear